our series rebuilding america showcases
people and communities that are finding
creative wills to build a better world
one project at a time this morning we
head to florida where the manatee
population is facing a crisis at least
600 have died so far this year many from
starvation poor water quality is
destroying the sea grass they rely on
for food arlene kiano traveled to
crystal river florida also known as the
manatee capital of the world to see one
community's innovative solution
when paul cross navigates crystal river
and kings bay florida he can't help but
remember when algae choked these waters
and suffocated native sea grass the
primary food source for florida manatees
we wouldn't even do manatee tours in the
summer months there wasn't as many
manatees that stayed because we didn't
have the food source and the visibility
when we did find those manatees was very
poor
as director of operations for plantation
adventure center a local dive shop cross
watched the river decline years ago
storms and septic tank pollution had
taken a toll
lush green beds of sea grass had been
overrun by thick mats of invasive algae
and with no food the manatees had nearly
disappeared
these tropical marine mammals can weigh
up to three thousand pounds and they
flock here in winter months to graze in
the warmth of the 72-degree waters when
their numbers dwindled along with other
marine life lisa moore realized the
river was dying personally i thought how
did i let this happen
how did i not know that this was going
on
and i've lived here all this time i
wasn't paying attention and so i kind of
felt like i needed to try to do
something the dying river compelled
moore a lifelong resident to create an
organization called save crystal river
in 2015 the group hired an aquatic
restoration company with an untested
idea
marine biologist ryan brushwood works
for that company sea and shoreline so
this is the bad guy the story uh this is
lingbia as you can see it's some gross
stuff it's like the stuff at the bottom
of the tub when the drain clogs right it
feels like the stuff that that clogs
your drains and here it was clogging
springs
and it was out competing
the grass just because of the sheer
quantity of it and over time as this
settled on the bottom of the seafloor
and started to cane it created a
sediment that was not suitable for the
plants to grow in
their plan was to send divers to the
bottom and use giant vacuums like these
to hoover up decades of algae and muck
they then plant seagrass back into the
bay by hand a painstaking expensive
process
armed with research from both the
company and independent scientists save
crystal river took its plan door to door
and then to state legislators in
tallahassee
eventually the group convinced lawmakers
to greenlight a 1.6 million dollar state
funded pilot project to restore about
three acres people around the community
a lot of them didn't believe that it
would work like i was the biggest
skeptic right when they started planting
grass and i'm like i've seen the
manatees in action i've seen them chew
roots from the trees like they're going
to devour all of this stuff
but six years later the beds of seagrass
and the restored areas are coming back
as are the manatees along with fish and
other marine life
as we saw on a recent swim with john
spann of plantation adventure center you
know five years ago you look down you
wouldn't see the bottom you couldn't
even see it in here and now you can swim
this hulk and out as you saw and you
could just see the grass see the bottom
and that's just that grass filtering
that water holding the sediment down
doing those good things that it's meant
to do residents here are also moving
from septic to sewer systems reducing
runoff that feeds harmful algae is it
starting to look like the river you
remember from your childhood yeah yeah
you go and you look at the springs
and you can see
all the way down in the springs again
you can clearly see the fish it's back
and it's just gonna get better i imagine
that must make you pretty happy it does
my children my grandchildren
all the other people that come here
visitors from around the world they need
to know what this special place is
the pilot program started with three
acres but they've since restored about
60 and they're hoping to restore more
than 90 acres by this time next year now
this is not cheap all that work will
cost about 40 million dollars but the
results are clear and now other
communities in florida with similar
problems are looking at this as a
potential solution
and manatees are so important to the
ecosystem yeah that's what people may
not realize that they keep it free of of
invasive species and overgrowth of
vegetation um and serve as a source of
fertilizer so that's why it's important
to save them yeah when we were setting
up the story earlier we were talking
about how humans have an impact on
things like this you say i was surprised
surprised here we are messing something
up again but we have an opportunity to
change it people have come together and
that's what i think is so extraordinary
about this story is that people didn't
realize at first what was happening
because they couldn't necessarily see
once they learned about it they figured
out how do we solve it what do we do we
got to go door-to-door we have to do the
hard work of convincing people convince
those neighbors convince the state
legislature now you have we need to fix
these you look very comfortable in the
water there miss kiana i love the water
fish i love those manatees elaine's next
chapter
of 20 years i'll gladly be your aquatic
correspondent all right why did course
go i like it we don't have one of those
yet elaine keano